امر وزير الدفاع الروسيه وسحب القوات
الروسيه الى الضفه اليمنى من نهر دنيبر في
خيرسون واقامه خط دفاعا للقوات الروسيه
على طول الضفه اليسرى للنهر وقال شوي انه
يتفق مع مقترحات
واستنتاجات للجنرال سرجين قائد القوات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا معتبرا ان حياه افراد
قواته تمثل اولويه دائما
بالنسبه لنا حياه افراد الجيش الروسي
اولويه دائما يجب ايضا ان ناخذ في
الاعتبار التهديد الذي يحيط بالسكان
المدنيين تاكدوا من ان جميع السكان غادروا
ابدؤوا بسحب القوات جميع التدابير للضمان
النقل الامن للافراد والاسلحه والمعدات
عبر نهر الدينيه
برج الجدي
في تقريبا قدمه لوزير الدفاع الروسيه
بلاده ستتخذ مواقع دفاعيه على محور خرسون
بطوله ضفه اليسرى لنهر دنيبر في اقرب وقت
ممكن
بعد التقييم الشامل
[موسيقى]
بشكل عام وهو امر لا جدوى منه في منطقه
محدوده على الضفه اليمنى بالاضافه الى ذلك
سيتوفر جزء من القوه والمعدات والتي سيتم
استخدامها في العمليات النشطه بما في ذلك
العمليات الهجوميه في محاور اخرى في منطقه
العمليات تحرك القوات سينفذ في المستقبل
القريب و ستحتل التشكيلات والوحدات خطوط
دفاعيه ومواقعه معده بشروط هندسيه على
الضفه اليسرى لنهرب